hi good morning thanks for coming around
so I flew in from Tokyo and I started a
company called Shira yagi which is white
goat we provide the iphone and android
app for news creation and i also we also
develop content discovery platform my
background is in physics and I worked
with daylight see data just a little
before the Higgs was found that they did
a lot of data modeling for estimating
the statistical uncertainties for his
discovery just wanted to give you a
quick shot about hydrated Tokyo which we
started last month so if you are ever in
Tokyo please let me know and maybe we
can find some interesting events or
whatnot so that this is the kind of
thing I used to do when I was a
physicist which was to build a model of
what we would expect in data and it was
highly confirmatory let's say very
highly theory driven and you'd build all
the parameters into the graphical
Bayesian model which enables you to
estimate the size of the uncertainty
that is any observation so this little
bump right here in the middle is it good
enough to call a discovery or just a
matter of fact that you don't have
enough samples and I just like like to
introduce a very unknown framework of
root which is a little like our but
develop I particle physicists basically
has this Python binding for pi root and
gives you access to all statistical Xin
minimization algorithms and so on
actually quite useful the very little
known outside of the physics and
particle physics industry so that's the
package that I used to develop for I
also enjoyed collect introduced who I
did this work with hit it we didn't make
it today but an interesting project that
he works on is a Mars surface project a
little like no I'm actually very unlike
the previous talk but he also deals with
data that is published by NASA from
space and he searches all the pictures
from the moon and the Mars uses deep
learning object recognition algorithm to
find signs of extraterrestrial beings
this is one that he has found in the
middle basic idea is that he feeds in a
lot of recognizable objects into deep
learning out with the message for those
things on moon and Sue Ellen and pen on
Mars so what we worked on for this time
is something related to this news
article that we provide which allow you
to follow any specific interests of your
choice and we collect news articles for
you something specific with the deep
learning Internet of Things we have
about three million topics to choose
from and that's why we do mainly natural
language processing as core development
but this time around we dealt with this
problem that we have to do with cutting
out thumbnails art of images in the
article so on the Left we have an
article that's about cat reacting to
seeing a dog for the first time but
obviously you cannot see the cat in the
images color in half
if you see the picture left one theme
that is quite popular in Japan is
animation and you can see also here that
the picture is color in the middle of
the face which is not very great for the
experience of the reader we get
something like 100,000 articles every
day so we cannot do the thumbnailing by
hand and that's when we started thinking
about this process so we have the image
and we wanted to identify the
interesting regions of the image by
using something called deep learning
which I will be introducing and deciding
which regions of the image has more
going on in terms of interestingness to
human and eventually finding out which
part to cut out so I thought has been
great in putting everything together one
part of the algorithm was written in
MATLAB which I had the lot of trouble
installing and then the second part was
C++ but fortunately there was a Python
wrapper for that which I have
successfully able to incorporate into my
ipython prototype and eventually Python
script so I also acknowledge that this
work was heavily influenced by the
burglar vision team you should really
going if interested in deep learning
they have everything on their website
and a lot of examples in ipython
notebook
okay any questions okay so the first
step in doing identifying the
interesting museums and image is
detecting which part to look at before
even being able to say what is in there
so for these two pictures that I showed
this red part was cut out by our default
strategy which is to take out the middle
part which is obviously not very clever
and what we wanted to improve on and
standard procedure for identifying the
subset of the image that might be
interesting was called a sliding window
which is basically to do for possible
size position and scale and aspect and
search over this four-dimensional space
on possible windows which typically
generates tens of thousands of windows
and if you're going to run something
like deep learning which takes a long
time to run that's definitely not a
method of choice instead lately
breakthrough has been reported in the
sense of segmentation so instead of just
choosing randomly all possible things
you cluster the patterns of image into
segments and you can see there are four
segments four levels of segments as
found by the algorithm and each segment
will generate one square
so please feel free to stop if you have
any questions so this typically
generates like 200 to 300 regions per
image not very time intensive process
probably few seconds so not to be
terribly fast but not terribly slow
either as I said this was implemented in
MATLAB which I have little problem
installing it beginning but then we
decided to run that at the subprocess
and quotes from Python and picked up the
output from Sify io package
and that defines all the possible
regions like this about 200 of them in
these cases and you can see they are
overlapping regions in different shapes
and sizes the second thing we wanted to
do was yes please
so these were generated from this
process of segmenting the image so this
is one segment where the color is the
same so you know it in terms of color
these are similar and it's decided to be
coded as one yes this is reasons legend
have any input yet for my knowledge base
to student this is just your mentor cook
yes yes
Oh
it is
the kids
I believe it is just color and most
simple did there are different features
you can fit into this out when we chose
to use the most basic feature at this
point
yeah sorry
I color generates more number of Windows
and great skill much less actually this
research is typically done getting a
higher recordin precision so with color
there's more possibilities of
segmentation so that's why you tend to
get more not necessarily better in the
sense of getting better out of many but
it does the chance of you getting the
right one increases if you have more
dimensions of segmentation
I'm answering your question
so via knows about cago yes yes yeah so
there was a competition on telling a cat
from the dog and you know the top people
here are like ninety-nine percent
accurate ons having dog from cadiz is
probably one of the most important thing
you should be able to do on the internet
and it turns out all the top people
according to the discussion that I saw
from cargo are using deep learning
nowadays which is really impressive but
I don't have much to say about the
theory and methodology behind it but
most of the work current best work is
based around convoluting your network
which basically convolute pixels of the
image in several steps and towards the
end of the step is really not
recognizable but from the experience
does give you a very high precision a
great thing is that the library's open
source what we use is cafe so not know
everything is open source but cafe is
know very well because it's open source
and develop very actively it's based on
crude or C++ which means you can use it
on gpgpu just with the single flag
and what's more useful with this is cafe
is just a framework to define neural
network so you can start to build your
own insert and remove any type of layers
but you have to train that a neural
network by yourself which means you're
going to need a lot of images with
annotation for example if you're in a
train on dogs and cats you have to have
a number of pictures of dogs and cats
here they can give you pre-trained new
networks published on github in this
case and what we used is what was
trained on 2013 imagenet challenge so
the way it works is you have the network
definition file and the trend network
which subsequently allow you to do
direct conditions so this is how we were
able to set it up through the Python
binding which you used provided by the
earthquake group again and you can just
the first thing on the list here is the
definition of networks which defines
what how many layers and what types of
layers are in the model and the second
thing and third thing basically is the
result of the training after running on
so many images that was provided for
this competition this time
and we fit in the windows that we
generated in the first step which is
about 200 of them and it's actually a
quite so step but you can start to see
that you're actually able to identify if
you can see this is in the order of best
match so number zero was very clearly
identified as domestic cat and domestic
cat with a wall apparently is a skunk
there's a few rubber erasers and rubber
band aid and things like that but but
you know much lower probability of
identification so that seems to be very
successful in this case the other damage
also pretty impressive that you can
identify person as well as high and face
powder on the face apparently um so that
also is identifying things pretty clear
so these can be interpreted as
probability if you put it in our
exponential salt log is a smaller number
yeah so minus means- and everything
below zero is not very good from our
experience to be precise yes
so the interpretation of this will be
deferential disappearing probability
very 1.0 to be
hard probably the answer logo
probability is what this is so if you
put this number and exponential that I
don't remember what the base of the
exponential was but yeah yeah right
right
ok
so the next step was very simple you
basically add everything up we tried
just selecting the top few areas as
compared to all the areas and you can
really also cut on like the probability
for example to get just the best areas
at this point we're just taking all
windows and just let the small
probabilities be in there because they
won't really highlight that much anyway
and you can see that the red region
there on the left is for the cat and the
right region you can see the faces and
the ties and the face powders
highlighted as red in there
so the final step is to crop the images
basically we have that window size 2.5 x
6.3 was just a size constraint that was
given by our you are designer we also
have square shape thumbnails which we
did enjoy at this time but it works all
the same we basically generate all the
possible locations for the windows that
we want to cut out and then calculate
the sum of the probabilities that is in
there which means selecting the square
that is containing the most amount of
interesting regions out of all the
selections and that eventually led us to
choose the parts that is incorporating
the interesting region as opposed to
what we were initially doing was to pick
up the center region so this has been
successful with with some things it's
not this was taken from an article about
a guy who was growing pot and busted
later on or something and you see with
this picture with the window size that I
had you can only capture the face part
or the cannabis part or any other part
and that definitely needs to be improved
on you can choose different aspect ratio
and we don't have the way of doing that
as yet although we can't see like using
different-size sorry aspect ratio and
compare the score between the two can
conceive of which one to select on
magnification is something we haven't
tried so we assume that the side of the
cropped image coincides with the short
side of the initial image you can
obviously do better on that by selecting
the regions that are that have higher
contents of interesting ness although
with this you need the next wrap on
Shane in order to stop the square from
shrinking so much if you're just
increasing the density of the
interestingness you would tend to get
just a very small region with the high
score so you need to apply extra
constraint in order to find relatively
large enough region
and there was a comment on you know most
of these interesting things were people
in cats and dogs and you know typically
those things so right now we're using
200 category deep learning algorithm
which is just way too complex you know
there are things like as you saw like a
rubber band and you know banded and
things like that which we typically
don't have in these images anyway so you
might as well just to face in gmail
recognition although for some things
accuracy would definitely decrease and
you know with machine learning out with
them unseen object knowledge it is very
well but it might be misidentified as
something else but really the the
probability of something unseen identify
something else is very very low
according to the output that we are
getting so with these things you can
fall back to just using those geometric
features instead of doing the object
identification although we haven't at
this point we haven't really tried out
yeah so you know also human is probably
more important in this picture than the
than the pan so that kind of decision
can be written into the code by hand in
order to prioritize some of the more
interesting things to give better result
yeah so that's all I got for today and
thank you very much for listening